-Guys, St. Patrick's Day
is this Friday.
-Whoa!
-Yeah, and if you want to...
[ Cheers and applause ]
If you want to get in the
spirit, check these out here.
The official "Tonight Show"
St. Patrick's Day
T-shirts and sweatshirts.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You can get them...
You can only get them at
the NBC Store here at 30 Rock.
-Really?
-Is that true?
No. Not true.
[ Laughter ]
-Can you get them online?
-I made that up.
I made that up.
You can get them...
Where else can you get them?
Online?
-Salvation Army?
-The shop at...
[ Laughter ]
No, they're not out yet.
-Oh, okay.
-They're not out yet.
"The shop hat"?
[ Laughter ]
-"The show pat."
-The shop at...NBC...
[ Laughter ]
We could've picked a different
font, maybe, for that.
...NBC Studios dot com.
You can get it there,
but today is Tuesday.
St. Patrick's Day is Friday.
You gotta really FedEx it.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, you gotta get...
-Get express mail.
-Gotta hit express mail, yeah.
These are
limited-edition shirts.
-Limited. Yes.
I think we made
like five of these.
-Really? Just five?
[ Laughter ]
You'd better hit the button now.
-No, here's the deal.
So, I didn't know how people
were gonna get these,
so I asked NBC Store, I said --
'cause the big parade is here,
St. Patrick's Day Parade
in New York City --
"Can you open early
so that people..."
'Cause every time we come in
to 30 Rock, it is jam-packed...
-Yeah.
-...on St. Patrick's Day.
And they said yes.
-Ooh!
-So, they're opening up
at 9 a.m.
If you know anyone
who's coming to New York City
for St. Patrick's Day,
9 a.m., you're safe.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, 9 a.m. Yeah.
-9:30, watch out. Yeah.
But 9 a.m., go into the NBC...
Look at these.
These are the new jam.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And Happy St. Patrick's Day,
everybody.
Appreciate it.
I could give out two of these.
-Give out two!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Yes! Come on!
That's what I'm talking about!
We'll be right back
with Bryan Cranston, everybody!
Come on back!